what's going on guys this is Rob and as
we continue with our series on various
characters from the Marvel Cinematic
Universe what we're going to be doing in
this video is we're going to be focusing
on Captain America Steve Rogers now what
we're gonna find so this video is gonna
be relatively short and the reason for
that is because unlike a lot of other
characters that we see in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Black Widow Hawkeye
and Nick Fury for the most part with
Steve Rogers what we see in the films is
really all we get the only the only real
exception here is the origin story of
how Steve Rogers eventually became
Captain America and so what we find here
is that the backstory at the origin
itself is given to us in a four-part
series titled Captain America first
vengeance and these are basically given
to us as coming up with tie-ins to
Captain America the First Avenger what
we learned here is that Steve Rogers
father had died during World War one
before Steve Rogers was born and as a
result he was raised by his mother now
where Steve Rogers demonstrated a desire
to join the military at a very young age
what we found was that his mother
encouraged his ambition to be a soldier
but also try to teach him that due to
his small stature due to his small
physical form that not many people would
really take him seriously and so as a
result he would basically have to fight
to earn the respect of others but that
his courage was really greater than most
men that were out there and of course
we'll see that come to fruition
once we see Steve Rogers actually become
Captain America now there also seems to
be some indication that perhaps Steve
Rogers mother is dying or at the very
least she's severely ill it's simply
just kind of given to us in terms of her
physical appearance she seems fairly
sickly here and what we'll actually find
later on is that she actually dies of
tuberculosis but the fact remains that
at some point Steve Rogers ended up in a
fight with some of the neighborhood kids
that were basically trying to force
Steve Rogers and handing over money they
were basically trying to shake him down
and that as a result when Steve Rogers
and these kids began to get into a fight
we found that Steve Rogers was joined by
Bucky Barnes now at this point Bucky
Barnes and Steve Rogers aren't friends
yet and they actually don't know each
other but what we find is that Bucky
Barnes is able to chase the bullies away
and so as a result Bucky Barnes and
Steve Rogers immediately become friends
now
eventually Bucky Barnes the Steve Rogers
enroll in college and during one of
their art courses pearl harbors attacked
by the Japanese and so the result is
that both Bucky and Steve want to enlist
of the military but due to the small
stature again of Steve Rogers Bucky
thinks there's really not a chance
for Steve Rogers to actually be able to
enroll in the military or to actually
successfully enlist in the military and
so because of the fact that they are
such close friends what we find is that
Bucky basically takes the time to try to
teach Steve how to fight as well as
basically how to put on muscle mass so
that he can have the kind of stamina and
the physical aptitude in order to be a
successful soldier and so what happens
as Bucky actually takes Steve Rogers to
Goldie's gym now Goldie's gym is a gym
we've seen before we actually see this
or we see Steve Rogers working out in
this gym when Nick Fury approaches Steve
Rogers to try to try to have him join
The Avengers initiative again just kind
of a little tidbit here a little bit of
a I guess an Easter Egg of sorts with
regards to the comic books in the film's
time into one another but again the
result here is that despite all the work
that Steve Rogers and Bucky Barnes put
into try to enhance Steve Rogers the
fact remains that Steve Rogers has
turned down that he's simply not allowed
to enlist in the military due to the
fact that he's simply just too scrawny
and so what this does as this basically
leads us into the very beginning of
Captain America the First Avenger when
we find that during the World's Fair
Steve Rogers sneaks off and tries to
enlist in the military but has
ultimately turned down where that being
said we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an and again I know this video
was very short but like I said they're
really on a whole lot of tidbits when it
comes to Steve Rogers in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe what we see in the
movies is really all we get with that
being said I will catch you guys later
peace
[Music]